[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kissing and this is the
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is a content
creator and the graduate of the
evergreen state college
benjamin boyce welcome to trigonometry
hey guys thanks for having me on
it's great to have you on you've got the
background you're right there in the
field of beautiful flowers
uh it's fantastic to have you on anyone
who doesn't know who you are just tell
everybody a little bit about
how are you where you are what has been
your journey through life how do you
find yourself having this weird zoom
chat with us
yeah well the the basic story is that i
was going through life and i had a dante
moment
and instead of going to hell i went to
this small college in the woods called
the evergreen state college and
uh i went there to study literature and
narrative specifically how it operates
how you pull it apart and put it
together and
what it does for and two people and
um about halfway through my time at the
evergreen state college
a new president came on and he empowered
some faculty
and they created the college's purpose
around
social justice but specifically about
racial justice and they began to
implement
ideas that i would ascribe to
i guess robin d'angelo is the most
popular proponent of these ideas
called anti-racism and whenever i speak
about anti-racism i'm putting that in
quotes and we can get into that
but that was in 2015 by the spring of
2017 the college kind of
collapsed in an absurdist version of a
race war and
the students took over the campus
accused this
very very progressive explicitly
anti-racist
institution of being the equivalent of
you know
the most white supremacist structure in
the world or just a part of that white
supremacist structure
they roamed the campus with baseball
bats they performed these things called
struggle sessions which is a kind of a
technical term they didn't know what
they were doing but they
pilloried and uh mocked and
yelled at and uh you know just kind of
broke down
various different authority figures and
they live streamed the entire thing to
the internet thinking that they were the
good guys
and it turned out that the world had a
different idea of what they were doing
and then one professor that they
targeted brett weinstein
went on to kind of challenge them
and then make what was going on more
public than it already was
seeing is that it was streamed online
well you're describing things that uh
sound uh slightly familiar in the last
few months don't they um
and this is really one of the reasons
that we wanted to to have this
conversation with you because
you you said just before we started you
felt like that would be a warning to the
world and i know brett did as well
you know we know brad we've met him
we'll we'll be getting him on the show
soon
he felt i think as well that this was an
opportunity for people to wake up
to what was going on and instead as you
said it seems to have been
more of a blueprint for how to move
forward so take us
you know kind of through that how this
example of student activism
running a mock now seems to be society
running amok or parts of society running
amok
yeah there's this interesting chicken
egg uh quandary
about do the ideas come first or does
the radicalism or the the
behavior come first so with regards to
what happened
in june of 2020 uh
i i think that we can see the build up
and then the explosion
uh that happened worldwide at least in
the western world about protests and
stuff
nominally about black lives matter but i
think that there was a lot of
just kind of pent up energy being
released because everybody had been on
lockdown
but that narrative uh that gave people a
reason
to protest specifically black lives
matter
and the various different things that
that means and
people try to control what that means to
for various different ends but it does
mean
different things you know there's the
statement black lives matter then
there's the organization then there's
everything that's attached to that
um so there's that layer that
if you look at what happened at the
evergreen state college there's a very
you know kind of basic explanation that
a lot of students had been
pent up all winter long and now they had
a reason
to just express a lot of energy they had
been given these tools
uh i guess kind of loosely based on a
marxist principle
of overthrowing the oppressor and
lifting up the victim
and kind of reversing the the scales of
justice
in a bid to equalize the scales of
justice so
the students had those ideas at hand
to justify what they were doing and to
explain
what they were doing to the world and to
themselves and to the administration
but beneath that beneath what the
students were doing
is the behavior of the faculty and what
i've done
because i was going to the evergreats
evergreen state college and
i was uh working in the media department
so i was on camera a lot of the time
filming a lot of these workshops and
seminars and lectures
i saw these ideas being implemented and
the ideas are very similar to you know
exactly the same ideas that are now
being implemented
in a response to the protests currently
so
there's been a big outcry about police
injustice and the oppression of
black people in america specifically and
now there's this entire set of ideas
called anti-racism that corporations and
school boards and
municipalities and various different
organizations are very are now
implementing as a response to that so at
the evergreen state college this is my
argument
is that the ideas allowed the protest to
happen
in current events the protests are
allowing these ideas to be implemented
so so i don't know if the ideas once
implemented what they will actually do
within
any given structure or institution but i
do know that they cause
an extreme amount of tension and
interpersonal conflict
and it fractures community it makes it
impossible to be
a human being to a human being i mean
benjamin you know we're talking about
students here isn't it a little bit
look students have always been how can i
put this you know
correctly kids so yeah she lives let's
just say [ __ ] you know
they've always you know been a little
bit [ __ ] if you go right the way
back to the 60s when my dad was at
university they were doing sit-ins you
know
protesting all the rest of it why is
this movement now so
dangerous as opposed to the movement of
the 1960s
that's an interesting question if you
if it depends on where the movement is
going to be implemented what we see
now is that i guess there was a letter
that was signed by
a hundred or 200 princeton uh
faculty and uh and masters students
that called for a reorganization of the
institution of princeton around
ideas of anti-racism around ideas that
they call equity and equity is not
equality equity is equalization
what equity does is that it takes
perceived privilege
and perceived oppression and it
decreases everybody who has the
so-called privilege
in order to lift up everybody that has
this so-called oppression
and what that ends up becoming is a
redistribution of resources
both in the sense of just monetary
resources
or in positions of authority but also
moral reparations that's what happens
and that's what happened at the
evergreen state
college was that once everybody was no
longer color blind
everybody was focused and obsessed with
color with race with gender
sexuality all these different vectors or
intersectional
markers of you know your privilege
oppression
matrix and what you were supposed to do
is
to apologize if you were a white man you
were supposed to apologize for your
privilege
and put yourself behind everybody else
and if you were let's say a disabled
black trans individual you were put
in front and you were given the moral
authority and it no longer had to do
with the soundness of your argument you
know or the content of your character it
had
all about it it stressed not only your
identity but how you could
maximize that identity to rest power and
to gain
attention uh so the ideas that
are being implemented they make
people go crazy and everybody depending
on where they are at life goes crazy in
a different way
and what i've been doing recently is
taking what i've
discovered and studied at the evergreen
state college and using those tools that
i developed
to examine how people in
new york city council meetings uh in
you know skype sessions and zoom
sessions are taking these ideas and
implementing the same sort of fracturing
of you know of community of community
of communalism of of i'm going to talk
to you as as a person
and using their identity to shift power
dynamics and to
i guess to forward some sort of justice
so the example i think you're talking
about is a
a meeting in which a woman is chastising
a guy for having his friend's black
nephew on his lap or son on his lap
and she's chastising him for this as
some kind of
evidence of racism while the boy's black
father's in the background
i think laughing his head off or
something along those lines uh
so i i see but uh benjamin you you bring
up and repeatedly bring up
this point about and anti-racism uh
in inverted commas why is it in inverted
commas for anyone who's just
who's not familiar with this whole thing
and they're just listening to this guy
and going
anti-racism i mean that that sounds
great we should all be anti-racist right
no if you're russian mate
um well mate i was gonna say if you keep
this [ __ ] up
as a white man i'm gonna make you
apologize for everything and uh you're
gonna get less speaking time on this
podcast just to balance out the
privilege
mean i'm seeing a brown woman she makes
me apologize for being a white man every
single day
i apologize anyway if that's what gets
you off man
you know what that is what gets him off
that's the real problem with this
with this whole dynamic but but listen
for anyone who
who who listens to to the to the to the
argument and goes
i'm against racism i'm against racism we
all are against racism so
why wouldn't you be anti-racist in in
in this uh in this way
there is a very short video that was
shared at my
place of employment now um where there's
a
video of ibrahim ex kindy who's the
author of how to be an anti-racist
and he says that in this video and i'm
paraphrasing here he says that
to to say that you're not racist doesn't
mean anything it's a denial
to to ignore racism to ignore color is
to actually strip
the experiences of those who have been
oppressed so
you can't be not racist anymore you have
to be actively anti-racist
and you'll you ask well what does that
mean
and when you get into this theology it
comes it becomes very apparent that if
you're a white person
you are operating in a state of
ignorance as to
the racism that is oppressing people
constantly that
everything that you take for granted be
it everything from
you know literally everything is racist
now if you start to look through the
lens of
of disparities of outcome
so like a baseball game is racist or a
wedding is racist or
you know technology is racist all these
different
parts of your life that you're taking
for granted actually
you can see that they're all racist that
everything that you do
or that you don't do is a marker of your
privilege and that you're constantly
perpetuating
this racism that's constantly oppressing
everybody else or if you're
in the minoritized group or the
racialized group
then you are constantly under threat
both from
macro aggressions which would be you
know history of uh
the oppression of of white people of
your race
but all these microaggressions that are
constantly uh operating behind the
surface
or these pico aggressions that you can
never actually
locate because we don't have the
technology to catch up to them but
you're constantly caught in a matrix
of struggle and of oppression and once
you
begin to internalize that kind of
process of
examining your life for all the things
that you did or didn't do
and it doesn't matter what you intend
right it strips your agency away
from you you no longer have any purpose
in life other than to fight against
this implicit bias that you have this
unconscious bias that you have and
my contention if you look at how it
affects people is that it
gradually erodes their ability to be a
normal person
functioning in the world because they
are constantly
overrun by this program that that
that's imaginary that's not really tied
to explicit acts of
being good or doing good or being bad or
doing wrong
it i'm i'm explaining in very general
terms so we should probably land on
something very specific but
i i see that the theology if you
listen to the people who believe this
they're constantly saying you need to
read
more you need to do the work more if you
disagree with them that's your fragility
there's all these
there's all these tactics that it uses
to make you to convert you into a
believer of the system
but once you're in the system once you
believe this belief
what are you supposed to do other than
tear other people down or tear yourself
down
i don't think of it as being
constructive
at all and why do you not think it's
constructive because isn't it
i mean we do talk about privilege but
some people are more privileged than
others there's different
types of privilege i mean that you know
that for instance if you might believe
in white privilege you're less likely to
be get stopped and searched as a white
person
then you are if you're black you know if
you're if you're a man you
you more likely to earn more all these
sorts of things isn't this a good thing
that we've been made aware of it
well that is a really good question and
i constantly try to
humble myself and interact with the good
intentions behind the ideas and
perform a struggle session on myself
because that's what it's kind of
inviting us to do is to really
grill ourselves and i think that insofar
as you withstand criticism
you come out stronger as long as you
don't give up your agency
your self-control your responsibility to
somebody else
as long as you maintain ownership over
your own guilt and shame
and don't give it to other people so for
example at the evergreen state college
towards the end of my tenure there
we had to go through mandatory privilege
workshops or anti-oppression workshops
and
in one workshop i was asked to detail my
privilege
and then to detail the privileges that i
don't have and
we broke up into small groups to kind of
to dwell on these things and
i was in the group with the speaker
who ended up being who was a evergreen
administrator
who figures into the documentary that
i've done she's a character in this
story
and i'm like well i don't see the world
as
vectors of privilege and underprivileged
i don't look at my world that way
why would i want to look at the world
that way and she's like well
you are privileged to not look at the
world that way and other people
aren't privileged enough to not see all
the disadvantages that they
have and then she detailed she was a
black woman but she detailed all the
privileges that she had about
being able to go on vacation and being
really happy that she was going on
vacation and she told a co-worker that
she was going to go on vacation and then
she realized that her co-worker can't
afford to go on vacation and
she was oppressing her co-worker by
expressing her own
you know happiness of being able to you
know take a break from
her work and when she went on this
lecture because i knew this is what was
going to happen and
i grew up in a christian church my dad's
a pastor so i've been exposed
to a lot of the mechanics of
christianity
and and i've always been very aware of
when they're being abused because i've
seen
the mechanics of christianity be abused
to control people so what i saw happen
in this lecture that she gave was that
she just kept on breaking down
everything in her life into
this very rudimentary uh very
narrow way of looking at the world of do
i have more or less than others
now when i resisted
giving them my privilege and giving them
my inventory it's not because i don't
have privilege
it's not that i it's not because i don't
have a deficit deficit of privilege
i don't want to use my envy i don't want
to
go through life envying everybody or
feeling
better than everybody which is what
you're supposed to do with this and
furthermore i don't want
them to be able to control my shame and
myself i don't want to go through life
apologizing for being a
white male that completely distracts
from whether or not i'm creating good
content right so my focus is on
making something good in the world and
the way that i can evaluate whether it's
good or not
is the effect that it has in the world
and whether or not i become
you know better than other people or
worse than other people
that's a very private thing for me to
evaluate and then to
either do better or to turn around and
help somebody who's
not as good off as me and using all
these tactics of guilt and shame
it's like a broken christianity it's got
all the sin but none of the redemption
it's got all the
let's talk about that because i think
the religious aspect of this is
interesting a lot of us have been paying
attention to this thing
particularly those of us who are
familiar with how religions operate
have begun to notice some similarities
and
the one worry to me you know i'm
skeptical of all religion or organized
religion certainly
because i see as a tool for manipulating
people and
imbuing people with original sin guilt
shame cetera apart from islam we're
quite happy with that make money clears
mate
yes absolutely clear you boys are great
well done mate saving us yes uh yeah
anyway uh moving swiftly on um so
there seems to be a lot of similarities
between what's happening and the one
concern that i've had for some time
which is what you put your finger on is
there seems to be one thing
missing from this new religion which is
any sort of possibility of forgiveness
any sort of possibility of redemption
that isn't
a product of being destroyed i mean if
you look at something like cancer
culture
it's not enough for somebody to uh to
come and confess their sins it's not
enough for them to apologize
they have to be destroyed they have to
be fired they have to lose their job
they have to be
shamed they must never appear on
television again etc
uh how much of of a religious nature is
there to this whole movement
well that's a really uh it's a really
interesting question that i think that
you can
go on forever to do that and i think
that
i've interviewed uh people who have
survived colds gone through colts and
there's this one book that i'm
i'm failing to recall right now but it's
an inventory of how
the cultural revolution in china or the
chinese
government implemented a totalitarian
state and
there was a number of different tactics
that they used and one of those tactics
that you use in a cult
in order to maintain a rigid belief
system and
therefore maintain control over people
is
methods of exclusion if people disagree
um either you're with the program
or you're out and then you are your
existence is erased
actually that's one of the literal
tactics of uh destructive cult is that
they erase your existence um so when we
talk about the religious nature
i think we really need to define what is
religion and this is probably this is
probably
beyond the confines of this discussion
but if we really want to honestly
critique in what ways social justice
activism or this current
spate of moral panic is like a religion
and
the different tactics or mechanics of
religious
uh you know structures that the
anti-racism quote unquote
or the critical race theory or all these
different you know
theories and theosophies uh behave
then you really need to understand i
really think or i would
push that you really need to understand
the function of religion in the
psychology
of the individual and of the group and
where the individual and the group
intersect
and and the negotiation between
individuality and collectivism
that religions prove themselves as
either destructive or constructive
through
i guess what i'm asking benjamin is what
are the similarities why do you say
this is like a religion um well okay
there's a
zealotry aspect of it there's um if you
look
at the ways in which a certain faction
of trans rights activism
operates and i'm making a distinction
between
transsexual uh transsexuals trans people
and then a certain behavior on the
internet
specifically towards a kind of
slightly well-known children's author
called jk rowling
the way in which jk rowling is being
attempted to be erased for simply
stating
kind of a nuanced opinion about the
conflict
between women's rights and trans women's
rights and how we need to have a
conversation about that and the ways in
which
radical trans rights activists feel
empowered to erase her existence
because her merely stating that women
are a different category than trans
women so
upsets these these individuals because
it erases
or attacks their reality and it shows
that their reality
is a construct of belief in
similar ways the ways in which belief
structures operate
if they aren't constantly given a
feedback into
producing something in the world if
you're con if you're not cons if your
belief
doesn't constantly focus or come back to
how do you feel um and what are you
doing are you being
a good person if it is instead
shifted onto are you changing the world
for the better
is the world bad or can it be better
then the locus of control or the locus
the focus is no longer on bettering
yourself it's about you know projecting
all of your evil and your weakness let's
just say your imperfection
onto the structures in the world and
then therefore you go after and you
assault these structures
uh in the world i'm i'm straying from
the point about making it a religion or
tying it directly to a religion but
there's just so many different
mechanics going on in here that i see
similarities to
and you know benjamin you know i i see
this movement and you know i
we started this journey two years ago we
started listening to people and you know
people like yourself i'm from venezuela
that means everybody who's watching and
listening can have a drink
so that's what we do at trigonometry
because i always reference my mum
but i've seen these ideas before they
brought new ideas i saw them in 99 when
chavez came to power
you know they're putting forward all
these ideas and you know
venezuela collapsed it's their crap
ideas
why do we keep perpetuating them why do
we keep going back to them
they there was an article that was
released
in reason magazine or reason.com and it
was based on
a scientific study of some sort and it
talks about the ways in which virtue
signaling
or virtue signal culture empowers
narcissistic sociopaths
and i've been seeing this over and over
again if you look at the footage of the
evergreen state college you see that
there's certain characters that get to
the top of the fray when
when the the organization shatters
then it becomes a pure power play and it
becomes purely theatrical
and in that type of environment certain
personalities get activated or rise to
the top so either
these set of ideas of kind of inspire
people to act like narcissistic
sociopaths or they empower people who
are already narcissistic sociopaths
i think that for a certain amount of
people it's really
attractive to be on the right side of
history and to
try to change the world it allows you to
merge into a story that has
which is so superhuman and so
otherworldly that you
in a sense get inflamed by this
transcendent
uh fire of being able to actually tackle
right now
400 years of oppression right now you
can be involved in
demolishing a system that has done
nobody any good or
every good that is done has come at the
expense of people
somebody else right it's a zero-sum
thinking with a
messianic message that causes you to
think that you're the messiah
and and it inflames your ego and then
you just go on this ego trip
um so i think on one level on the
psychological level revolutionary ideas
are really suited for people who are
discontent with themselves
and who don't have a strong moral
foundation that constantly causes them
to focus first on themselves and then on
the world and i think that
in a certain way because of social media
because of facebook the way that
facebook twitter and instagram are
designed
it rewards narcissistic behavior and
these ideas uh kind of breed upon
narcissistic behavior so
it's just i think it's a conjunction of
very similar different things
and people being ignorant of the outcome
of these ideas
you think part of it is also an
ignorance of history because
it seems to be these kind of cycles
throughout history where
it takes a few generations for people to
forget what
what was a really bad idea so suddenly
you've got 20 year olds now explaining
to me
how great communism is when i come from
the soviet union right
and that's because they haven't been
kind of you might say they haven't been
indoctrinated against
it and to some extent they've probably
been indoctrinated
into it by their marxist professors at
university do you think
this is kind of the cycle of history and
which is back to the 1930s
if that's the case then what i think we
should well here's the problem with this
but i have an idea why don't we just
sandbox these ideas
in the uk and in america and give
give a city over to the communists and
say okay
let's run your experiment abolish the
police empower social workers create a
communist government
i nominate hull you've never been to
whole benjamin it's not no
should i go there uh yeah if if you
don't like uh having a good no that's
unfair on the people of whole i'm sure
it's a great town
yeah it really isn't i mean we love the
people of hull but hull
not so much anyway carry on thank you
and in a certain extent
evergreen the evergreen state college
story is a perfect example of how these
ideas play out
but built within this activist rhetoric
built within the very foundations of
critical race theory
of white fragility theory of all these
different ideas
is a shifting of the blame away from
the self so if evergreen fails which it
has
evergreen ran an experiment and it
failed
everybody who still believes in
evergreen or believes in these ideas
that
you know kind of took over evergreen
shifts the blame to tucker carlson
shifts the blame to the right-wing media
shifts the blame to the uh
yokels down the street that voted for
trump right so they can
they're literally unable and this is my
main criticism or the damning
criticism of at the evergreen state
college is that
they ran an experiment like good
academics but like bad academics they
were unable to actually do
the work of examining why it went wrong
where it went wrong so
even if we do give over michigan to the
black lives matter uh
government and they fail which they will
because everybody who generates income
everybody who is productive will leave
because their productivity will be given
to the loudest people in the room
who don't want to be productive they
just want to be right
it will fail it will collapse and then
they'll blame it on
capitalism they'll always blame it when
you say evergreen
failed what does that mean like is it
still there
i mean what's failing about it what's
failed about it
so if you look at the numbers and i'll
try to make a nuanced point about this
if you look at the numbers
the evergreen state college ran their
social justice
experiment in 2011 they made just uh
social justice
their you know guiding one of their
guiding principles in 2015 they made
anti-racist indoctrination the way in
which they're going to achieve social
justice
in 2017 they uh
fomented and uh justified in after the
fact this
huge protest that went absolutely viral
because it's absolutely stunning how
everybody acted in this event
and then the feedback from the
environment was
i don't want to go and get this kind of
education i don't want to go to the
evergreen state college and their
enrollment has plummeted
dramatically the administration has
blamed everything
except for the protest they'll say well
maybe the protest did something but
really we think that it's just
the economy is different or blah blah
blah blah they've gone so far as to
pay a marketing team i'm 90 certain to
suppress my videos on the google search
rhythm
algorithm i'm i'm the one who has
reported constantly on evergreen and
they stripped about a year ago google
kind of flushed my
videos from uh search results of
evergreen and two weeks before then
the college hired that team so they've
tried to do everything they can to
do good but nobody wants to go there
nobody wants to go to evergreen state
college and this is the nuance point
even if you do want a social justice
education even if as a student you want
to go and change the world
and to hell with understanding it the
goal is to change it
why would you go to the evergreen state
college which proved
that they can't even teach you how to do
that effectively
if you look at how the students
overthrew the
world they're so ridiculous they made
complete fools of themselves
as did all the administrators so even if
you want that kind of education which is
what they're offering
why would you go there if you could go
to any other college literally any other
college in the united states
but it isn't part of the problem
benjamin is that and i'm a former
teacher i was a teacher for 12 years
we have raised a generation of children
you know
to be you know to essentially see
themselves as victims
we try and sort all their conflicts out
for them it's a very selfish culture we
want to protect them
we have essentially raised a generation
of adults now
to be self-indulgent and narcissistic
and think the entire world is about them
so can we really blame them when they go
out and they start behaving like this
well see in my reportage on the
evergreen state college and now in my
reportage on current events
i'm not really concerned with the
students or
let's call it the youth or the kids or
whatever i'm concerned with the
administrators i'm concerned with the
adults in the room and if you look at
the adults they
like the people who are running we have
lost our sense of authority
it's not the generation that's acting
crazy we have lost our ability to have a
strong a
positive strong role model of authority
we don't trust authority
we've gone down this road of
deconstructing and deconstructing so
long
that we can't even we can't stomach
anybody
drawing a line in the sand we i think
that the fabric of our society has
become so uh reactionary in a sense
progressively reactionary that we we had
to elect
a very belligerent authoritarian
authority figure not authoritarian
figure but authority figure
in trump just to kind of show us that we
like show us the dark side of what we're
missing i i think that
if you look at washington state on every
level if you look at the evergreen state
college
seattle and the governor they're all
very weak leaders
who suppress who suppress the uh let's
say the conservative faction who want to
get back to work
constantly suppress the people who want
to get back and get the economy
rolling and then constantly coddle the
people who want to overthrow society
like it's filled with hypocrisy and
weakness
and it's interesting so you say it's
filled with hypocrisy and weakness
don't you think one of the things that
we saw in this country which
still to this day gets me upset is the
fact that you know
the black lives matter movement now we
can all agree that black lives matter we
can all agree
that you know racism wherever it occurs
should be stamped out
but if you look at the black lives
matter organization and you see
what the they want you know overthrowing
capitalism
defunding the police you know i don't
know the word they use for the nuclear
family but basically it's eradicating it
we all know that these are terrible
terrible ideas
but in our country right now the head of
the labor party
criticized abolish the police said it
was a ridiculous idea
and he's now been got he's now checked
himself in like yesterday
after the day before for unconscious
biases training
you're laughing mate we're [ __ ] no i
know
what else do you do when we're all
[ __ ] except for laughs i'm a classical
uh camusian you know it's just like the
world is absurd at this point
and he was head of the criminal justice
uh
he was head of prosecution that was it
he said of prosecutions
in this country he's now checked himself
in for unconsciousness biases trainers
but anyway
my point is why don't we have people
who look at these simple things like
blm1 and go
this is quite clearly neo-marxist
nonsense
and we shouldn't be following it yeah
yeah well i
you have to look at the way and there's
ways to spend what i'm going to say that
might be a little conspiratorial theory
but i do think that there's an
iterative process of how we got to this
point it
happened in education and it's happened
in the media
the media has been uh captured or
compromised
where there's such a strong hold on the
narrative that always goes in one
direction that
if three white supremacists
show up on a street corner they're going
to use that
as you know proof that white supremacy
is on the rise
if an entire city gets torn down by
you know progressive activists or antifa
activists
that will just be oh some people went
overboard but it was a peaceful protest
like there's
on every level of analysis the
media shifts the blame and doctors the
narrative in such a way that it makes it
impossible
to for you to simply say no that is
ridiculous
so it the the narrative's being
controlled
and insofar as the narratives being
controlled everybody who's speaking
against that narrative
is atomized we're all like we're in this
kind of this
network of just individuals talking to
each other which is a particular
weakness and strength of those who
do embody or embrace individualism is
that we kind of have to do it together
and
let the institutions fall in a way and
let the authority
that they're expending on these stupid
ideas just eventually completely drain
them out but
it'll take a long time for princeton to
collapse it'll take a long time for the
new york times
to you know to collapse but that's where
they're heading these huge trees
are rotting from the inside out well
this is what i wanted to talk to you
about which is the way forward and i'm
not saying the three of us are going to
come up with the solution right
here right now but it seems to me that
one of the big problems that we face as
people
you know with different political views
and we're not necessarily all on the
same page but the one thing
that we embraced as you said is the idea
that the individual is sacrosanct
and should not be judged on their group
characteristics but rather on their
character which used to be
a very fashionable idea now that's
racism
but but how do we deal with this because
it seems to me that
this idea that you know dave rubin is a
big fan of this idea you know
the marketplace of ideas and if
someone's got bad ideas the way you
defeat it
is with good ideas well i know it
doesn't doesn't seem to me that we are
in a marketplace of ideas i think we're
and have probably always been operating
in a marketplace of emotions
and in the marketplace of emotions being
upset
being quote unquote a victim being uh
oppressed
etc that trumps almost anything else
uh certainly trump's reasonable
reasonableness
facts or trump's rationality so how
how do those of us who believe those
things are more important triumph in
this sort of
cultural struggle i recommend
and this comes from my experience as a
teacher i was a teacher too before i
went to the evergreen state college i
was
actually a preschool teacher so i don't
really know if it was my
12 years teaching preschool or my four
years at the evergreen state college
that gave me the tools to
analyze this behavior but yeah we really
have to
take the long the long play the long
game
all of this emotion
that's bright that's vindictive that's
vengeful that's victimizing
and that's victim-centric that's
narcissistic
it doesn't have a long shelf life it
once it expends everything all the
resources around itself
there's nothing left for it and that
works on a moral
level too it works on a artistic and
aesthetic level too
so i do think that rationality should be
and reason
should be promoted i don't think that
they're going to be enough
what we need is better art what we need
is better storytelling what we need
is to engage people's curiosity
rather than their victimhood to engage
sorry let me just interrupt you there
uh just very briefly you talk about this
idea of
uh this will burn out uh you know the
emotion explodes and then
but but one of the things we're seeing
as we've talked about is that
that initial explosion of emotion by the
kids generation that francis asked you
about right
you said you're not concerned about them
and you're right i think
to be concerned about the people who
respond to that the adults in the room
who then change institutions from the
inside out
yes and and so what you're left with
that initial emotional explosion
changes in institution and then we have
something like the bbc in this country
which a lot of us used to respect and
and i still hold on to the idea of a bit
of the bbc being potentially
a neutral arbiter that can be used to
bring the country back together
but but it's been infiltrated by people
with this mindset
the institution has been changed from
the inside out and they now
and i know this because i talk to people
at the bbc i get invited onto their
programs etc
and and some of their people will tell
me in private you know
i can't say what i think in this place
right so if the institutions get changed
by that initial explosion of the emotion
i'm not sure your analysis is correct
because if that if the structures change
then
as i said we're [ __ ]
yeah well okay the
the the spike of how it's going to burn
out with the
raw motion is going to be much quicker
than how it's going to burn out with the
implementation
of you know systemic racial bias
training and all this stuff
i'm not saying that's going to happen
overnight with regards to
the shutting down of actual creative
interesting critical thought but
that's why we have to rely on the
marketplace
you know just the capitalist marketplace
with regards to media
people will get really tired of
ingesting
the crap ton of intersectional uh proper
media that's now being it's going to be
put in place and
now because of this black lives matter
themed revolution
it's going we're going to have a whole
bunch of media that's
writing through this social justice lens
and
that that has already been tested in
smaller markets like with comic books or
with
uh video games and stuff and it it just
it doesn't satisfy it's not really a
satisfying story
and only so many people can be a victim
right only so many people can
actually embody that victimhood in a
manner that they gain all the attention
much more people want to hear
the hero's story much more people want
to hear the off-color joke
and so we're going to go through a
period
it's going to be several years of
suppression
of voices and of content
thankfully we have the internet but we
don't know if it's going to have to
be refigured to allow these ideas to
perpetuate but
people's interest will go towards other
things now
in a work environment and if you're
working at a job you can't afford to
leave the job
you're going to need to actually study
these ideas and come up with good
arguments against them
and figure out ways to allow yourself to
speak or
make connections with people who you
don't think agree with you but actually
if you
study people's behavior people more
people don't want to go down this
than do it's going to take a lot of work
i'm not saying it's easy
um and that we can't just you're right
we can't just like let it blow through
us we actually have to actively
interact with it but the feedback
mechanism will be
that eventually it's just not going to
be satisfying on an aesthetic level
or productive on a fiscal level and a
lot of companies are going to say
why are we spending billions of dollars
on this bias training
that's making my employees not like each
other anymore let's get rid of that
go back to work but benjamin you sailed
this and
i'm sitting here and i'm agreeing with
you isn't it pretty terrifying
that you're going to be going to work
and you're not going to be able to say
what you think
and all of a sudden you know you think
well if i say this if i disagree
with it i don't know the concept of
white fragility i'm going to lose my job
i mean that's a
that's a terrible way to live isn't it
yeah
yeah yeah i'm not i'm not saying that
we're in a good spot we're not in a good
spot
but going forward i think we do have to
reify
what the central values that we hold
dear and if we
have to hold those close to the chest
that is an opportunity for us to really
examine
why the ideas that we believed in and
then that now are
out of fashion are very important so we
really have to get down to basics go
beyond just free speech get into you
know what is individualism
what is property what is uh freedom of
association go back
into the roots it's a wake-up call to
our civilization
if these ideas turn out to work if
anti-racism
turns out to work and if robbing from
the
supposed privileged and giving to the
so-called depressed actually creates a
better society
then maybe it was just our white
discomfort all along but if not
then we have to get back and really use
this as an opportunity
to get back into what are we not doing
right with regards to the young people
that are growing up and with regards to
what we allow our institutions of media
and education
and so on to to to actually promulgate
oh by the way constantine if this system
is shown to work we're going to turn up
we're going to
rename our podcast white discomfort
oh mate uh why an olive discomfort i'm
going with olives
if i'm going down you're going down two
weeks ago you were saying i'm not white
you make up your [ __ ] mind
i am the victim i am oppressed get on
your knees
schrodinger's victim over here there we
go uh
so um but one thing that i wanted to ask
you was
what do you think is going to be the
effect of
this type of thinking on our cultural
institutions we're already seeing it a
little bit we've already seen
the bbc plunge i think it was a hundred
million into
into diversity i can't even remember the
language they used i got so
turned off by it but what do you think
is going to be the impact on our
cultural institutions with this type of
thinking
uh having studied the psychology of it
what it does
and i might be proven wrong this is just
a [ __ ] all i have is a crap
crap load of anecdote i'm not a
scientist i haven't done a data analysis
but i just i witnessed it from a
narrative standpoint from a human
standpoint that what it does
is that it suppresses uh
meritocracy it suppresses meritocracy it
suppresses
the proof is in the pudding it
suppresses judging somebody by their
output
uh it rather uplifts judging people by
how they can be victimhood so what
you're going to see in your work
environment
is that there will be unstable
personalities who see this as their
opportunity and those unstable
narcissistic sociopathic personalities
were actually kept in check more or less
not perfectly
but kept in check by the stress on
productivity so if you give a narcissist
the goal of being good because they're
being good for everybody else let's say
like if you put a
ceo let's say you have this sociopathic
ceo
who doesn't give a [ __ ] about humanity
but if you reward him
by tying his behavior to rewarding other
people
then you basically kind of harnessed
that very
selfish energy that has no morality this
this behavior however within this system
of morality that's being implemented
doesn't
produce anything anymore other than
destruction
so um i i don't i'm trying to be
optimistic but at the same time
realistic with the fact that
institution after institution will go
through some variation of the evergreen
state college
where we weak leadership will cede its
authority
to bad actors over and over and over
again and the proof will
be in the destruction of the
productivity or
the educational merit or the whatever
product your institution
is concerned with creating will be
diminished
by this ideology that's what it's going
to do
so basically just to convert that into
kind of uh
ordinary uh examples it would be
for example the bbc will already have a
massive campaign to defund it to stop
the taxpayer funding an organization
that increasingly caters to a very small
slice of the population
it's going to be things like that it's
going to be people not watching
mainstream media but watching
trigonometry or watching benjamin boyce
or whatever
because they feel that that's where
getting good information from
it's going to be you know universities
the one thing i was going to ask you and
i think
it's an issue that bothers a lot of our
viewers and it bothers me and it
bothers francis as people who you know
who are considering bringing children
into the world is
how do you protect your children in this
environment
from being indoctrinated because the
school system is riddled with this stuff
yeah that that is a actually i'm very
concerned about that that's a very
big concern and the only way
to protect your child from this which
has captured
many many educational institutions is to
kind of get to work i think that a lot
of people were asleep at the will i
think
i think life was so good for let's just
say gen x that we didn't show up to
council meetings
we didn't show up to these board
meetings we didn't show up to the pta we
didn't show up
you know we allowed the activists to
take over in a certain way so we have to
start showing up
we have to take the reins upon ourselves
to tutor our children and
critical thinking uh to to to expose our
children to rich ideas because
the education system which we were
allowing to run on its own
was taken over by these other things so
we have to do the work ourselves in a
way
so the responsibilities on us if you
don't agree with this stuff you have to
start your own thing
you really have to be able to say if
if i don't believe in this ideology will
i
sacrifice my job to live in a better
world
like that's what you're gonna in certain
cases that's what you're gonna have to
do that's what
certain people have done you know i was
really lucky because i didn't have
anything to begin with right but brett
weinstein
in a way like he he made good but he was
an example of somebody who sacrificed
his
career and there's plenty of other
examples of this for the truth
and you know there's people at the
evergreen state college that i talk to
now who
who spoke up and who couldn't deny their
conscience
a lot of people did deny their
conscience and now they're paying the
price
and i think that i think that it's an
opportunity any great tragedy is an
opportunity to really prove your
character right if we do
think that content of character is what
matters then
god damn it prove it then if that's what
you really didn't show that you have
character
and which we involve sacrifice he's
talking to you francis
yeah mate i've sacrificed enough
certainly anyway
trust me but doesn't it also mean like
so
i'm on the left uh i always have been
former teacher blah blah blah all the
rest of it
and the way that this ideology has
riddled
the left and left this thought which
let's be fair has some excellent ideas
doesn't it mean that we're just never
going to get elected ever again
um that's that's a really good question
we'll see what happens in america it's
crazy it's absolutely insane we do not
have
a trustworthy left party
and i guess you could always say that
they were always just like neoliberal or
they weren't trustworthy in all these
different ways but there's no set of
ideas on the left that have not been
infiltrated by this incredibly virulent
and destructive ideology and so what do
you do you're basically
you're basically alt-right adjacent or
left prostrated
right at this point in time like this
those are your two options so there has
to be this
politically homeless uh you know this
centrist kind of
weird encampment of people just pitching
tents
outside of the main structures that are
either you know something that you can't
agree with if it's too conservative with
you
or something that you can't agree with
because it's too uh
crazy for you so
well we're [ __ ] aren't we right good
positive unless you like camping
yeah we're all going to learn to camp
very soon but benjamin listen it's been
a pleasure talking to you and i think
you make some
excellent points as someone who's seen
how this has played out on a smaller
scale
um and how it might play out going
forward i think
i think you're right it's about people
taking responsibility and that's what
you know francis and i have done that
and as you say it's you know it's
my favorite one of my favorite movie
quotes is from fight club and says
it's only when you've lost everything
that you're free to do anything
and i think you know us doing this show
you doing what you do and there are lots
of other people who
could try in as best they can to step up
and uh we know a lot of people who watch
the show who are stepping up in small
ways and in big ways
to try and uh make i mean you know
there's the mayan and narcissists coming
out to change the world for the better
so thanks for coming on uh we've got one
more question for you
and it's the same question we always end
the show with which is what is a one
thing that we're not talking about as a
society
that we really should be uh i think
i don't think we're focusing on our
arches our arch support enough anymore
like when we're going
to get footwear i think one thing that
we've just completely lost
is is that footwear going to affect my
back in a positive or negative manner i
don't think we're really thinking about
the entire human being
as you know a network of bones you know
we're so involved in our emotions that
we're
losing track slowly of taking care of
our body that was a facetious answer i
never know what
not to talk about because it's not about
what we're not talking about it's
about what we're not allowed to talk
about like one thing that i think is
that
i don't think it's healthy to always be
questioning everything to be
a skeptic about everything but whenever
you're in a situation
where you're not allowed to question
that's when the questions need to be
asked the most so whenever you sense
that there's something that we can't be
talking about
you know so that that that's kind of my
answer is that
that's kind of my job is to kind of
smell that that
where the conversation is falling apart
and go towards that so
i never know what that's going to be
because there's so much of it out there
right now
and it's a man who suffers from flat
feet thank you for
raising that it's important somebody had
to do it and you did
so thank you you stepped up when it
counted man uh but listen benjamin if
people want to follow your work
you've got a youtube channel obviously
uh where else should people go to
to check out what you do i'm on twitter
at
benjamin a boyce i do a lot of pithy
sentences i think sentences are just
like that is what i want to be known for
all these videos you know that's just a
vehicle for sentences so that's
my main output that in the youtube
channel i highly recommend if you
haven't heard what happened at the
evergreen state college story i've made
a
20 part documentary on the events
showing
everything that happened from found
footage and documents that i got through
the college
with very minimal editorializing in it
and that's on my youtube channel it's
linked right in the uh main page it's
very good
and uh very scary all at once so if you
don't want to watch
source 17 or whatever it is check out
the evergreen documentary held by
benjamin boyce
uh thank you for watching guys and we
will see you very very soon with another
brilliant episode make sure you go and
follow benjamin
on the youtube subscribe to his channel
and hit him up on twitter as well
thanks for having me guys thank you very
much benjamin absolutely
uh don't forget we've also got live
streams and we've also got
episodes our live streams are tuesday
thursday friday
saturday always at 7pm see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word